bonjour genre pour corinne et stéphane
il est temps de découvrir les secrets de
fabrication de leur boisson préférée la
bière artisanale conçu depuis un an et
demi dans ses locaux d'olive et d'une
part je vais récupérer ce qu'on appelle
les drêches c'est le lait céréales
maïté noms dont les sucres ont été
épuisés et de l'autre part je vais
retirer mon plus clair qu'est le mou de
la bière pourrait être un jus de
céréales tout simplement est qui et qui
va être sucrée une rigueur une
authenticité locale appréciée des palais
les plus curieux dont on voit comment
c'est fait du départ jusqu'à la fin et
que ça dure quasiment un mois le
processus de fabrication et c'est super
intéressant
les gens connaissent un petit peu le rap
comme une région à poèmes vinicole mais
par contre c'est avec la bière c'est
beaucoup plus et venez chez nous
beaucoup ne savent pas comment il fait
la bière wii qui sont étonnés ça peut se
comprendre beaucoup pensent que la bière
s'est fait dans la journée dont il faut
être un peu patient la bière ces quatre
à cinq semaines
mais la patience paye une passion pour
produire ces bières blondes et ambre est
commercialisé avec mille autres
références prisés par les consommateurs
et les professionnels de la région
voilà neuf mois que laure en disant berg
a sollicité ce brasseur ou obtenir son
propre breuvage une commande bienvenu
après 18 mois compliqués avec 40 % de
chiffre d'affaires en moins on attend
encore quelques mois et la rentrée sept
ans je pense nous amènera des belles
choses dans les faire une reprise de
l'activité pour les associatifs qu'il ya
ce type d'idées volume pour les pour les
fûts pour une brasserie
ce qui compte beaucoup c'est quand même
fin de volume mais le volume c'est les
fûts et voilà donc bien des campings
je lui trouve un petit goût légèrement
vanillé et j'aime la vanille donc tout
va bien
et puis la bière à la main un autre on
investit 2000 euros sur sur une bière
locale après voilà on va la
commercialiser sa pose pas de problème
d'ailleurs on est même en avance sur les
objectifs de vente sur cette bière
locale 2000 euros pour proposer 300
bouteilles d'un breuvage aux stands à
consommer en tout temps bien sûr
toujours avec modération